bonjour jean marc sylvestre merci d'être
avec nous ce matin alors bruno le maire
a confirmé ce troisième confinement et
il va coûter 11 milliards d'euros de
questions ça va profiter à qui et qui va
payer
oui à la question simple réponse
peut-être un peu plus compliqué
d'ailleurs alors cette troisième vague
se traduit par un durcissement des
mesures restrictives donc des fermetures
de magasins supplémentaires avec des
activités qui vont tourner au ralenti à
cause du télétravail tout ça a été
chiffrée effectivement à 11,6 milliards
d'euros qui bien sûr vient en plus ça et
vient de s'ajouter à tous ceux que l'on
paie déjà dans les confinements et les
couvre feux précédent alors il ya des
commerces qui vont être indemnisés de
leurs chiffres d'affaires
il ya des allocations de chômage partiel
qui vont être versés tout ça est grosso
modo supportable pour l'instant sauf que
ça va faire baisser sans doute la
perspective de croissance économique sur
l'année savent à peu reculé
les dates de reprise de l'économie ça
peut aggraver le déficit donc la dette
le déficit public va augmenter de 8 et
demi à 9 % la dette pourrait passer à
118 % on va frôler les 120% du pib alors
beaucoup de commentaires mais de
l'action bien sûr sur les difficultés
économiques que ça représente mais
globalement il faut pas ajouter de
pessimisme à l angoisse qui existent
déjà par ailleurs l'effondrement total
n'est pas d'actualité la ruine totale
dont on parle parfois n'est pas
d'actualité l'économie française résiste
assez bien d'ailleurs
cette résilience tient à la décision
évidemment de préserver tous les actifs
de production en état de marche
quoi qu'il en coûte ces actifs ont été
protégés ils sont protégés pratiquement
depuis un an beaucoup y compris les
contrats d'embauché
grâce au chômage partiel et hormis
l'allemagne ben je vois pas beaucoup
d'autres pays dans le monde qui ont fait
un tel effort alors certains secteurs
sont sévèrement touchée il ya des
manifestations aujourd'hui partout en
europe
conte sur le transport aérien
l'hôtellerie la restauration les biens
de culture qui sont encore fermés mais
ces secteurs doivent pouvoir repartir
dès que les conditions sanitaires seront
restaurés ces secteurs vont repartir
d'autant plus vite qu'ils ont accéléré
leur mutation digital notamment dans la
restauration il
les restaurateurs ont fait
efforts colossaux pour pour pour
s'organiser même si certains sont
borderline avec certaines repas
clandestins on l'a bien vu dans
l'actualité ces secteurs vont partir
dans plus vite qu'ils ont accéléré leur
mutation technique ils ont défini leur
produit différemment et puis la demande
la demande et les solvables puisqu'il ya
de l'epargne qui a été accumulée par
l'ensemble des français c'est d'épargné
est disponible va pouvoir alimenter ce
pouvoir d'achat alors il ya certains
secteurs en revanche qu'ils vont avoir
du mal à repartir
air france par exemple alors ça ça va ça
va être un gros problème qui va coûter
extrêmement cher et c'est parce que ces
secteurs là était malade avant qu'il
tombe aujourd'hui en difficulté grave la
crise de covin on a fait des secteurs à
risque avec des facteurs de morbidité ou
de comorbidité ils sont incontournables
et qui apparaissent assez violemment
jean marc sylvestre vous parlais tout à
l'heure de la dette cette date y va il
va bien falloir la rembourser bah oui
vous avez totalement raison parce que
tout ça c'est de l'argent qui est
emprunté les mesures de soutien consenti
en 2020 et puis les manques à gagner
surtout en recettes fiscales bruno le
maire a prévu un plan de relance pour
cette année 2000 21 900 milliards on a
déjà dépensé la moitié sains et puis on
attend la quote-part du plan européen de
750 milliards d'euros alors ça c'est
assez en retard on aura pas avant juin
juillet parce que on a du retard à
l'allumage à la lourdeur des décisions
administratives ya un certain nombre de
pays dont l'allemagne d'ailleurs qui
rechignent un peu à soutenir ce plan de
mutualisation mais si on additionne tous
les plans de relance on s'aperçoit que
nous sommes grosso modo au même niveau
que les américains puisque joe biden qui
a repris 1 le plan trump en l'augmentant
de 2000 milliards de dollars et bien on
arrive en gros à des sommes équivalentes
en europe le seul problème économique de
la france est de financer cette dette et
vous avez totalement raison de le
souligner parce que cet argent basse et
de l'argent qu'il faut aller chercher
sur les marchés financiers nationaux ou
internationaux
selon une majorité d'experts on devrait
pouvoir le trouver cet argent d'ailleurs
on l'a trouvée jusqu'à maintenant et
sortir du piège
il ya trois conditions un il faut que
les taux d'intérêt restent bas ils
resteront présents dans le combat parce
que structurellement l'amour
égalisation fait que nous dégageons des
taux d'intérêt à 0 2 le stock de dette
doit être compensé par un taux de
croissance relativement plus fort que le
prix de la dette parce que si le taux de
le taux de croissance est plus fort que
le prix de la bête on rembourse
mécaniquement sans même s'en apercevoir
et puis une troisième raison est bien il
faut que cette croissance revienne à un
taux relativement fort et qu'on stoppe
surtout stop le l'endettement et qu'on
reconnaisse est de gérer les dépenses
publiques de façon un peu plus sérieuse
est restrictif que ce que nous avons
fait fait jusqu'à maintenant il faut
donc qu'il y ait de la croissance
il y en aura mais il y en aura à une
condition ultime c'est que les
vaccinations puisse protéger la majorité
des êtres humains a revu un logiciel
électronique fonctionne mais son
démarrage son démarrage ne dépend que
des campagnes de vaccination alors
est-ce qu'il peut y avoir aussi des
risques de bugs dans tout ça des risques
de bugs
l'inconnue c'est toujours la même elle
porte sur la capacité du ministère de la
santé a sécurisé la campagne de
vaccination alors oui peut y avoir des
bugs du côté sanitaire parce qu'on les
cosaques les a collectionnées déjà les
bugs la france a raté beaucoup de choses
dans la gestion sanitaire de l'épidémie
est encore actuellement on peut avoir
des doutes sur la capacité de cette
campagne de vaccination à atteindre ses
objectifs en quand on regarde ce qui se
passe dans l'éducation nationale où vous
venez de faire un reportage
il le démontre magnifiquement on n'a pas
assez anticipé
il va parce que cette vaccination il
falloir à vacciner tous les enseignants
mais il aurait fallu assise accompagnée
avant avant la vaccination global
accompagner tout ça de mesures de
testing on a un peu raté de mesures de
traçage qu'on n'a pas très bien réussi
on a en a pas réussi à sortir les
autotests par exemple ils vont sortir en
pharmacie que que la semaine prochaine
on n'a pas réussi à faire en sorte de
d'isoler de façon relativement précises
comme l'ont fait un certain nombre de
pays les cas positifs n'ont
paradoxalement la france s'en sort bien
sur le plan économique en europe mais
sur le plan sanitaire
ça marche pas alors s'il fallait
distribuer des bulletins note puisqu'on
est à l'école aux différents ministères
sur la façon
on a géré la crise l'exercice est très
simple l'appréciation englobe
l'administration et demie signalement
sur nul pratiquement pour le ministère
de la santé mention très bien au
ministère de l'économie avec l'aide de
beaucoup d'entreprises qui ont pris sur
leurs initiatives sur ce qu'ils ont
réglé à ce nombre de problèmes ne saoule
souvenez-vous les machines et où les
tests
souvenez vous même les vaccins
aujourd'hui mes initiatives ont permis
de gérer correctement cette situation où
ce et éviter évitait le pire mais sur le
plan économique il n'ya pas grosse
inquiétude
on verra la date de vaccination global
il permettra de fixer la date de la
reprise et au moment de la reprise
je pense qu'il y aura une explosion
d'économies sur vevo main tendue des
confirmands l'année dernière en juin
juillet août lors alors que l' aquila
ils allaient l'économie française avait
repris très violemment
merci beaucoup jean marc sylvestre âge
rappelle que vous êtes éditorialiste
économique merci beaucoup